you said you would overcome uh drug
addiction what was what was the uh your
your poison uh Zan's Percocet and Lee
that's hard those are all the hard ones
all the hard ones all the worst ones man
um those are the kind of ones yeah I got
addicted to zans and lean when I was
probably about 17 years old you know I
was taking his hands drinking lean
smoking weed like every day I ain't
gonna lie look I used to I got to a
point where my brother he had to tell
you the story I wish he was here we was
in New York one time you know like 17 18
I'm already G herbo I'm already well
little herb or whatever the [ __ ] I'm
already traveling I'm doing shows I'm in
other states and [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying so I'm on the road battling you
know the trauma that I'm trying that
I've been dealing with for so long you
know what I'm saying but um
I'm like one day we was in a hotel and
I'm seeing my brother right there I'm
just like taking zans take one I was
already off and I ain't feeling we just
in the room chilling like 30 40 minutes
go by I'll take another one
like an hour go by I'll take another
week look at me like hey bro what the
[ __ ] you doing you feeding my brother
like hey [ __ ] I just watched you
literally take three three of them yeah
hose ends back to back you drinking what
the [ __ ] is you doing right I'm like 17
18 years old even my brother five years
older than me yeah he's like hey man
what the [ __ ] you on yeah I ain't even
realizing you feel me like I ain't even
feel like I'm feeling I'm like I ain't
high he like [ __ ] I'm looking at you
[ __ ] you is high yeah you feel me like
I was battling with that [ __ ] crazy bro
because I couldn't sleep like trauma
things I'm seeing bro like I mean it
numbs you dealing with you I've been
saying some Wicked [ __ ] bro I didn't see
my best friends brains blew out in front
of me I've been seeing a lot of [ __ ] bro
for real like it just got to a point
where I couldn't live with my
grandmother my grandmother died in 2016
bro I missed the last probably year and
a half of my grandmother life because I
couldn't live up I couldn't live there
bro I couldn't live that [ __ ] was
trying to kill me I couldn't you
couldn't be around her because you
couldn't be around the person who I love
the most
life because of where she lived right
and she ain't had no choice she on
[ __ ] section eight right she can't
move you feel I'm saying like that [ __ ]
bothered me still to this day bro and I
don't want to get emotional about it but
you can only imagine like that's just
one thing